movies are meant to inspire us scare us
make us laugh and make us cry but
sometimes they just leave us absolutely
totally confused 2017 was a particularly
dense year of confounding movies so get
ready to get confused here are a few
films that will bust your brain and
consider yourself warned there will be
spoilers the bad batch set in the near
future the bad batch is about a group of
criminal xl's who've been left to live
in a lawless cannibal riddled wilderness
the neon drenched backdrop of comfort
the central society where humans eat
rabbits and not each other serves as a
stark contrast to the mania going on
behind the fence where civilization and
civility are null and void in a grim
introduction Sookie Waterhouse's
heartland is tattooed with a prison
number and dumped in the desert
soon after she's abducted and drugged
and her limbs are amputated and devoured
by a group of cannibals months later she
stumbles across a mother and daughter
scavenging the landscape and upon
realizing they're cannibals she takes
out the mother and abducts the daughter
as an act of revenge
the women turn out to be the family of
Miami man who sets out to search for
them and makes an unlikely acquaintance
ship with Arlen along the way he doesn't
know she's responsible for his
daughter's disappearance of course so he
asks her to help with the search and the
pair strike a peculiar friendship Jason
Momoa scare achter doesn't bother to
hide his brutality and arlynn makes it
known that she hates his kind and
somehow it just works but this is where
the plot starts to get lazy and go off
the rails
Harlan does help Miami man find his
daughter and when they're all finally
reunited somehow it's never revealed
that Arlen put Mommy Dearest in an early
grave instead she rejects a chance to
stay in comfort and shack up with Keanu
Reeves leader character and ventures
back into the bitter Beyond with Miami
man essentially taking the place of the
woman she acts by the end the movie
makes so little sense that the title
couldn't possibly be more appropriate
personal shopper featuring apparitions
half open doors and things that go bump
in the night personal shopper has all
the trimmings of a traditional
supernatural horror but Olivier a
ciasses thoughtful meditation on grief
is anything but ordinary swapping
jump-scares for ambiguous psychological
trickery the film centers on Kristen
Stewart's Maureen a personal shopper by
day and spirit medium by nights
after her twin brother passes away from
a heart condition Maureen sets down a
paranormal path of discovery to make
good on a deal the pair head during his
lifetime the first to go would contact
the other from beyond the grave
throughout the film
SAS crafts a nuanced story that
interweaves the narrative of Maureen's
grief with the gruesome slaying of her
celebrity boss this is where the lines
between reality the paranormal and her
own welled imagination begin to blur
whether Maureen really is communicating
with her late brother or being
manipulated due to her fragile mental
state is far from clear leaving a lot of
room for interpretation and puzzlement
ashay asks himself later clarified the
meaning of the movie that Maureen was
simply grieving her loss the only way
she knew how
but anyone who saw this in the theaters
last year was almost certainly
scratching their heads after the credits
roll colossal this is a monster movie
with a colossal twist after repeated
drunken misbehavior Anne Hathaway's
Gloria is thrown out of her boyfriend's
apartment in New York determined to get
her life on track she returns to her
hometown in New England where she bumps
into an old friend in jason sudeikis 'as
oscar and her drinking problems persist
at the same time director nacho beagle
Ando throws up surprise after surprise
starting with the casual introduction of
a monster attack in Seoul South Korea
that may seem at odds with the film's
palette but the attack does have a
direct link with glorious story as she's
somehow inexplicably linked to the Beast
what Oscar discovers he also has the
same monster replicating superpower
colossal follows another tonal shift
Oscar shows his sinister side callously
manipulating Gloria by threatening to
use his own monster to kill thousands of
people if she doesn't comply with his
demands Oscar's chilling behavior turns
the monster storyline into a conduit for
emotional and physical abuse and leaves
Gloria with the challenge of overcoming
her demons both real and imagined
vigeland au uses monster movie tropes to
provide a shrewd commentary on very real
issues and while it is executed well
it's bound to give audiences whiplash
with so many bizarre swerves song Tucson
Terrence Malick's filmmaking style
frequently divides opinion and song to
song is no different Moloch depicts a
love hexagon at the privileged in a way
only he can weaving a complex web of
infidelity betrayal broken hearts and
sentimentality in fluid edits and
unconventional framing the narrative
itself is straightforward set in the
cutthroat music industry Rooney Mara
hopeful musician Fay begins an
ill-conceived relationship with Michael
Fassbender as powerful music producer
cooked to help her career
however she falls in love with Ryan
Gosling's BV another musician working
closely with Cooke and begins a
relationship with him as well after
forming a three-way friendship faith BV
and Cooke navigate the landscape of
music festivals and cocktail parties as
phase infidelity continues what makes
song to song both brilliant and baffling
is its replication of memory and
consciousness the story unfolds as if
Moloch cherry-picked individual
characters reflections directly from
their brains and scrambled them together
into a collective stream of
consciousness that warps the linear
narrative structure like raw memories
themselves the flow of the story
abruptly diverts changing direction on a
whim and by the end of it it's hard to
figure out what just played out
on-screen a cure for wellness set in the
breathtaking backdrop of the Swiss Alps
no one can claim Gore Verbinski's
aesthetically pleasing thriller lacks
ambition in fact a cure for wellness
suffers from being overly ambitious like
its mountainous terrain the story twists
turns and ultimately disorients its
audience events initially appear
straightforward dainty Hans
up-and-coming executive Lockhart is
tasked with retrieving his company CEO
from a hiatus at a Swiss Wellness Center
to his frustration the staff at the
center won't allow him to talk to the
guy and on his way out of the center
he's involved in a car crash he awakens
from the accident to find himself a
patient at the same Wellness Center with
his leg broken and covered in plaster
it's then that Lockhart and his crutches
squeaked their way through a
hallucinogenic journey filled with
freaky imagery the center is hiding a
terrible secret and Lockhart is on a
mission to find out what the slow reveal
of the truth is frustrating and
borderline nonsensical as we discover
the centre's doctor has been extending
his own age by siphoning off substances
from patients
by the time the film serves up its final
surprise though the audience's appetite
for weirdness has long been satisfied
raw julia duke renault brings a fresh
look at eating human flesh with raw the
second cannibal themed movie on this
list
like the bad batch raw gets under the
skin because of its eerie authenticity
replacing a dystopian wasteland with the
familiar backdrop of a university this
realistic depiction makes the French
Belgian horror too strong for some at
the 2016 Toronto Film Festival there
were reports of audience members
fainting such a visceral reaction is
understandable raw begins like an
innocuous coming-of-age tale with a
young woman leaving home to join
veterinary school where her sister is
also studying during an unforgiving
hazing process she breaks her strict
vegetarianism when she is forced by her
sister to consume a raw rabbit kidney
and this is when things get weird really
weird having had a taste
our heroine then embarks on a
cannibalistic quest for flesh that
quickly grows out of hand
Sukarno doesn't broach such a taboo
subject or to it asleep raw is hard to
comprehend but the conclusion will leave
chills down your spine and a bite mark
on the memory mother director Darren
Aronofsky said the script for mother
poured out of him like a fever dream and
the result dives to surprisingly dark
depths of nightmarish vulgarity ultra
violence and barbaric bewilderment
it begins with Jennifer Lawrence's title
character and Javier Bardem hem living a
life of quiet solitude when Edie
Harris's man makes an unsolicited sat
there door asking to stay followed by
his wife Michelle Pfeiffer's woman much
like the flames that engulfed the house
at the beginning and ends events rapidly
blaze out of control as more and more
people arrived its entirety takes place
within the claustrophobic and confined
setting which eventually descends into a
warzone and an all-out assault on the
senses on top of graphic violence
mothers most unnerving moments are
delivered with everyday social
non-conforming malice where strangers
show complete disregard for her wishes
trying to decipher the sir reality at
face value left many moviegoers guessing
which is why Aronofsky had to come out
and tell people he meant this to be a
biblical allegory mother represents
creation him represents God and the
people are the Destroyers of both
considering how bad e the movie is
though it could mean a whole bunch of
other things or nothing at all at the
same time killing of a sacred deer
Yorkist lanthum us is no stranger to
eccentricity he directed 2016's the
lobster a story about a hotel
where it's single residents have 45 days
to find a new romantic partner or else
they turn into animals initially the
killing of a sacred deer appears less
bizarre scratches scalpel under the
surface though and lan Themis outshines
his earlier efforts the story focuses on
Colin Farrell's talented surgeon Stephen
who befriends a boy named Martin
sprinkled with the directors trademark
deadpan dialogue
there are numerous quirks and dark humor
moments that require close inspection
there's the weird obsession with body
hair and Nicole Kidman's character
pretending to be an anesthetized patient
just to be kinky and that's nothing
compared to the stories core Martin is
out for revenge
believing Ferrell's character to be
responsible for the demise of his father
Martin tells Stephen he is placed a
curse on his family in an act of
vengeance to undo the curse Stephen has
to kill a member of his own family or
else they will all die slow painful
deaths much - Stephens exasperation
Martin's curse begins to manifest as his
children lose the ability to walk
now how martin enacts the curse is
anyone's guess he's seemingly able to
make symptoms come and go those looking
for answers won't get anything concrete
either as it's compounded by an
ambiguous ending that gives little away
the Snowman expectations were high for
this film because director Tomas
Alfredson was the mastermind behind one
of the finest horror films of the
generation Let The Right One In and the
Snowman boasted Michael Fassbender in
the lead with such talent on both sides
of the camera how did the film end up
with a 7% score on Rotten Tomatoes the
issue certainly wasn't Joe Nesbo's
source material his novel of the same
name as the seventh featuring alcoholic
detective harry hole following the same
premises Nesbo's novels for a depraved
serial Slayer whose trademark is to
leave a snowman at his victims houses
unfortunately issues with production
melted any hopes of the snowman being a
hip Alfredson admitted that a Thai
production schedule left the film as a
big jigsaw puzzle with a few pieces
missing the result is it disjointed a
confusing experience with choppy editing
important storylines that are never
concluded and characters introduced in
later disappearing with no rhyme or
reason making matters worse the
marketing campaign for the film became
an unintentionally hilarious meme which
is hardly the way to make audiences take
your Thriller pic seriously thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Applause]